commencez vraiment vincent d'amour très
bien merci me recevoir chez les heureux
on est très content que vous soyez là je
vais dire vincent koh lanta c'était un
rêve pour toi je crois oui c'était un
rêve pour moi de le faire est de nous
c'est un challenge aussi pour moi à
relever et je suis très très heureux de
l'avoir fait alors on va voir une petite
compil qu'on vous allez voir vincent
non franchement c'est la rigolade de koh
lanta regardez ces quotas record est ce
qu'il fait c'est enfin moi je ok je vais
faire ça mais après si c'est pour
m'éliminer le sixième ou septième
changement personnalités béninoises
c'est un truc de dingue j'attends mon
tour
[Applaudissements]
en effet pour s'entendre pour basson
alors que tu étais préparée
techniquement pour un oui ouais je
m'étais préparé physiquement ça allait
je faisais beaucoup de natation je
courais aussi pas mal j'allais la salle
de sport le matin donc tranquille koala
castaldi et ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a
pas eu un personnage mais l'an passé un
bonheur absolu
j vers l'est c'est extraordinaire mais
tout autour de vous entre les plats une
en anglais les stratégies les vôtres les
conseils vous attendez à devenir le
héros de koh lanta n'ont pas du tout
franchement pas du tout j'ai vécu une
aventure pleinement et moi en âme et
conscience finalement le musée
m'attendais pas à un tel retour et c'est
en tout cas un vrai plaisir très très
touché de voir tout ça dans la rue c'est
la folie ou pas franchement des fois oui
on
vient souvent me voir at a fait des
supers bons choix on assure vincent
toujours des photos etc
mais ça avec en plus alors ya autre
chose qu'il ya un truc a beaucoup fait
rire les téléspectateurs c'est quand tu
avais fait une petite boulette t'avais
sortie de collier mais pas du tout pour
moi c'est comme ça tchouki demain vous
serez tous ray ou alors j'ai une arme
secrète en ma possession que je devais
utiliser quand vous allez prononcer le
mot réunification c'est effectivement
une arme secrète
vous allez pouvoir la jouer est ce que
quelqu'un d'autre aurait trouvé larmes
secrète de la réunification
chez les jaunes
heureusement nos vélos
est ce que ces normes secrète a révélé
au moment de la réunification
non en fait jusqu'au conseil de la
réunification
primo n'y est pas là non pas 100 en un
instant vous venez de perdre le secret
que vous gardiez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dormez les règles 2 y de koh lanta de
fou une boulette là mais bon c'est le
foot très vite au moment même où je
crois que c'est pas qu'on va s'en
remettre la main bon il était déjà trop
tard c'est vrai que c'était déjà trop
tard et à tous les autres
les autres familles ça rigole c'est
magnifique c'est un masque franchement
je te dis moi je sais qu'il y en a
certains qui trouvait qu'il est passé de
rebondissements dans cette saison mais
ça c'était avant ton coup de maître la
semaine dernière et voiture est surpris
tout le monde en votant contre une
ancienne membre des jaunes chine
c'est un stratège durait depuis les
rangs du colis vont pas lui faire gagner
je vote ben ali
tu sors note alliance je te souhaite la
prochaine fois ok comme ça serait pour
toi
il fait tout ça
ça m'énerve je fais pas ça bah oui est
carrément j'ai même une des menaces en
me disant si tu veux pas ça au prochain
tour on te sautent vincent j'ai plus un
accord
janice les aventuriers de la tribu
réunifiée ont décidé de vous éliminer et
leur sentence est irrévocable
je te mangerais je vais peindre
maintenant que les rouges me suivent la
girouette c'est ma tête à la petite
silhouette du roi d'accord je fais mon
jeu moi aussi tu as un moment un petit
peu compliqué si sûr maintenant je pense
que voilà tout le monde réagit avec ses
émotions avec ses sentiments
donc elle avait une perception du jeu
j'avais la mienne aussi donc voilà j'ai
dit n'était pas je trouve que vincent
vous êtes vraiment à acheter un haut
potentiel vraiment émotionnelles parce
que je trouve que vous êtes à la fois
perché lunaire sincère vous êtes une
bouffée d'air frais dans cette dans
cette édition est pour moi vraiment vous
êtes un ovni dans la galaxie kolontar
après on n'a pas vu est là mais on n'a
plus jamais vu un candidat comme ça
voici un petit job et maniéré vous avez
pu être complexé l'an justement ce ses
manières et je trouve que justement vous
êtes tellement touchant moi je vous dis
les ados ont ajourné 3 il vous adore et
que voilà c'est vachement bien tellement
aussi aussi elle même elle tenait son
football castaldi vous adore mais la
1200 enfants nés après après ça les gars
n'étaient pas comme des oufs sur toi
aussi un acte au regard et à prix délits
compliqués bah ouais c'était chaud si on
nous a dit non moi je voterai magan
lamotte et shanice nom et et shanice le
conseil tous les rouges ont voté chaalis
l'enterrement vincent vient de trahir sa
famille pour moi c'est le tournant de
l'aventuré pas vraiment il vient de tout
détruire ce qu'on a construit vraiment
c'est pas une petite trahison la ration
il a voté à nice donc pour moi il lui a
planté un groupe loup dans le dos il
nous a tous trahis que je veux plus en
entendre parler
pour moi c'est comme si c'était un
pantone à ceux qui disent que tu les as
trahi que tu existes plus pauvres
qu'est ce tu le tuent leur réponds bah
moi je trouve ça dommage est ce qu on
est quand même dans un jeu il faut
savoir aussi prendre du recul on était
tous là pour jouer pour aller au bout de
l'aventuré maintenant
enfin si sur tous les coups de pression
moi que j'ai pu recevoir genre quoi
comme coup de pression va justement
lorsqu'on dit les cet échange avec janis
cet échange avec thomas où il me fait
clairement comprendre que si tu veux te
pas leur thune gic le prochain conseil
même ça enfin moi c'était justement déjà
que je peux pas accepter ça surtout que
j'ai l'air avec communiqué le fait que
j'allais pas voter voilà donc
non moi je trouve ça dommage qu'on ne
sait pas plus maintenant enfin en tout
cas là en ce moment avec la diffusion
puisque là on revit je pense aux tâches
et un petit peu laventure donc j'espère
que voilà tu es fier de s'apaiser par
mon essai c'est bien ce que je viens de
mon aventure très heureux de l'avoir
fait encore une fois c'était mon rêve
donc si je suis une vraie fierté
je pense que tu ferais un jour les all
stars alors la question c'est faut-il
être meilleurs stratèges qu'aventurier
dans koh lanta pour toi faut être
meilleur stratège
je pense qu'il ya plusieurs compétences
quand même mais c'est sûr que le social
c'est hyper important en cette aventure
parce que vont forcément si on tisse des
liens des stratégies indécis on fait des
alliances avec les autres on a forcément
plus de chance aussi d'avancer
pour moi c'est vraiment le social qui
prime après c'est sûr que voilà sur les
épreuves il faut être passé par exemple
bien sûr oui on va obtenir toutes les
zones où les images en taisant droit qui
se sont aimés bien menacé c'est myriam
mais elle a tenté un gros qu elle a
essayé un retournement de situation
ouais on va pas se mentir ça n'a pas été
facile de faire du recours et aussi leur
et maggie voulait c'est d'aller utiliser
leur a juré du tout
mais madame depuis aujourd'hui elle
s'intéresse beaucoup à ce que je dis
elle s'intéresse beaucoup à
l'agriculture à mon métier je suis très
contente de partager tout ça avec
quelqu'un est prêt il voulait venir vous
asseoir services à domicile
tish à l'est d'el icha des machins bon
c'est bon aussi mais bon on n'est pas à
la crèche
dix ans ont passé mais je pense que
c'est passé puisque ça fait leur
sentence est irrévocable
ouais là même bouder il m'écrit qui me
disent y est mon préféré
même si beaucoup des rois alors c'est
quoi ton plus ton plus beau moment de
l'aventuré c'est que t'es quoi tes
craintes avant et est ce que c'est
vraiment très dur de faire koh lanta est
ce qu'on dit c'est vraiment la plana
sont vraiment pas on notera monde au
repas auquel pas rien du tout ça tu es
sur la nourriture on en a pas besoin
d'en face on le voit on perd tous du
poids
mon plus beau moment c'est forcément
cette première rencontre avec denis et
cette première rencontre avec tous les
aventuriers on se dit que c'est vraiment
concret que là on va vivre notre rêve
notre aventure mon aventure donc c'est
là où tout se concrétiser c'est à garder
des postes ou pas bien sûr pour effet d
amis sur rien à qui tu parles plus du
tout par contre il y en a avec qui c'est
toujours un petit peu plus d'ici ça bat
notamment avec janis bien sûr assure un
petit peu à la folie bah c'est pas la
folie en ce moment surtout que l'un avec
la diffusion à la ja touré qui remonte à
faire surface donc je pense que c'est
c'est facile pour personne mais bon
maintenant
alors cette semaine on sent qu'on se
rapproche de la fin eq la tension monte
c'est simple il y avait clairement une
ambiance de merde sans nom
franchement alors là c'était franchement
le monde c'est une castaldi après
l'opération
comme le dit vincent à un moment dans
cette tribu des ex-jaunes il fallait se
soumettre ou se démettre pas du tout le
monde avait son avis est ce que vous
confirmez ce qui va bien sûr je veux que
vous avez dit donne pas la roche qui
fabrique les mois je confie au dire de
ce sketch
moi je sais que vous appelez ça un
sketch franchement et couvrir je sais
que les jeunes aussi ont voté contre ou
derrière j'étais venu pas sereine à 100%
mais mais un petit peu confiantes quoi
et non c'est clair que je paye les pots
cassés du manque de confiance de mes
coéquipiers je trouve qu'ici c'est une
bonne bande à paul ii de d'hypocrite
comme on est en république bordel de
merde répond crise il ya l'hypocrisie
dans koh lanta tout ça ouais bah tu es
forcément des fois obligé de mentir ces
voix là on est dans un jeu il ya toutes
sortes de stratégies aussi donc on l'a
vu déjà dans le passé avec candy ceci
donc voilà être plusieurs
alors je vais te montrer des candidats
qui restent je veux dire à tous la vie
qui va gagner voilà tu veux alors
regardez voilà alors voilà tous ceux qui
sont encore là qui va gagner pour toi
bats tous c'est pour gagner
non mais dis moi mais à tous ont hâte ce
potentiel je dis toi moi on verra oui
oui on verra ce qu'il en sait on
dès vendredi si tu gagnes ils sont mille
euros tu vas en faire quoi moi
j'aimerais bien offrir une machine pour
une machine pour les poireaux en fait
mes parents parce qu'ils sont arrivés
plus tard l'appel et la mâchoire c est
ce que ça me tient à coeur parce que
justement moi j'étais là au south richer
ses supérieurs en nombre à d'ailleurs
tous les agriculteurs ceux du malin et
du coup c'était moi je les fais aussi
pour eux ce que ça voulait pas reprendre
la ferme sont fiers de toi je te regarde
tes parents bah j'espère qu'ils sont qui
sont fiers et oui je pense qu'ils le
sont alors vendredi il ya eu un truc la
terre alors lui ont fait des gros bisous
s'il ya eu comme une rigolade vendredi
une candidate n'a pas pu participer au
jeu de confort pour gagner une nuit des
rêves dans un hôtel après des semaines à
dormir sur le sable et elle a eu un lot
de consolation
vous allez voir c'est la consommation la
plus horrible de l'histoire des
consolations muskin à moi fois je
n'aurais même pas pris le lâchez moi j
n'est une villa
avec piscine la possibilité de vous
doucher et de profiter d'un formidable
buffet du site
vous évader du gant
je rêve de bruncher tous les jours dans
un cadre paradisiaque donc oui
effectivement je me fais vraiment bavé
et rêver il y en a un qui ne participera
pas seulement
ici vous allez regagner votre campement
et regardez vous allez partir avec 4
anatomy le rêve de brunch et tous les
jours et vous allez repartir avec elle a
bien fait de regarder parce que sous les
quatre bananes pour y avait quand même
une arme secrète à m alors oui c'est ça
que j'adore dans cette saison c'est
qu'il ya des twists formidable et
maintenant denis et dans la boucle c'est
à dire qu'ils nous font passer par un
ascenseur émotionnel ou novices mais là
c'est inhumain de faire ça à cette
pauvre candidate nommée quoi c'est vrai
c'est sérieux c'est évidemment on a un
twist encore un rebondissement qu'est ce
qui se cache sous les 3 pauvres banane
c'est une immunité
quelques chutes shell
[Applaudissements]
je remettais sais qui tu peux qu'est ce
que tu préfères dans tout ce qui reste à
démontrer nombreux mois c'est flavio
flavio ça peut faire pour être en finale
avec flavio bah oui j'aimerais bien
ouais tu as tu t'entraînes l épreuve des
poteaux
je ne suis pas entraînée à l'épreuve
quand on fait qu'hollande à moi la
première fois à la mairie d'un mois si
demain je fais koh lanta sur la tène le
maire je parle plus je mène schüco
maputo avec mes grandes si non je me
suis dis pas je me suis pas entraîné
avant de partir à l'épreuve des poteaux
chat à patates envie d'y être bien sûr
bas j'ai pas trop lente à produire toute
épreuve ou pas je redoutais l'étais pas
je pense que oui on est on est tous à
avoir des poteaux c'est ça me touche
c'est génial qu'est ce que t'es mon avis
franchement y'a pas de personnes que
vous détestez thomas a certainement non
je ne déteste pas
c'est dans le cadre du jeu dit sûr qu'on
ne s'entendait pas maintenant si je
déteste c'est comme ici paru il ya des
gens qui s'en vante pas dans le cadre de
l'émission car derrière ils sont hyper
potes n'ont jamais comme ça la santé ou
20 cents j'ai bien sûr que je suis très
très fier très heureux et question envie
de faire après koh lanta balaj justement
alors grâce à koh lanta mais j'ai
compris vous avez vraiment une fibre
enfin je m'intéressais vraiment à juin
ouais et du coup je me suis lancé une
formation pour devenir coach de vie et
coach de la côte de carrière mais la
mode et on sait pourquoi pas donc pas
envie de continuer la tenante fins bas
on verra on verra franchement je veux
pas si t'appelles tu ferais le ca
laissons la diffusion pour le moment
mais c'est quand même une du très bien
très très belle aventure je suis très
heureux de l'avoir vécu c'était
tellement fort en émotion que
franchement je la trouvais oui j'ai
sauté
j'espère fondant turcotte était notre
chouchoute fait d'énormes michel gentil
merci